[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
Thank you very much for coming.
This is my first time
speaking at a movie theater.
I think your seats are
fully automated, so
recline, get comfortable.
I'd also like to
welcome everyone
who's listening online.
I'm here to help you transform
your business with Cloud TPUs.
So this talk is
about supercomputers,
machine learning.
These multiple
generations of custom
A6 boards, systems, and
whole supercomputers
that we've designed
here at Google,
and are making available
through the cloud.
I've got lots of
interesting things
to say about our recent
product announcements,
some new performance and
cost information, and more.
But before we get
to that, I just
want to set the context
here for those of you who
are new to the field, or new
to hardware acceleration,
especially in the cloud.
So people have been calling the
end of Moore's Law for decades
now, so I'm a little
nervous about this.
But I think it's finally over.
Sequential processing
is finally plateauing,
so you can't just wait
for new processors
to come along and take
your sequential program
and make it
magically run faster.
And we're reaching this plateau,
after this amazing wild ride,
just at the moment that
businesses have to manage
more data than ever before.
Now, you're all familiar with
these different kinds of data.
In the images and
video category,
you might have
billions of images
of user-generated
content, or live video
streams for video
calls and short videos
that people are
sharing with each other
or sharing to show products or
real estate or other spaces.
You've got product imagery
for retail and e-commerce.
You'll hear a little bit
more about that later.
Do you have spatial imagery,
in ever higher resolution,
medical imagery, navigational
imagery for autonomous
vehicles, robotics,
manufacturing
for quality control, and more?
In the text, speech,
and audio domain,
there are messaging
systems with people
sending uncountably
many messages every day.
Product reviews, forum
comments that you need
to moderate and rank and route.
New voice interfaces that are
taking the world by storm.
Support requests that can
come in many modalities,
whether in-person, texting,
voice calls, even video.
You got lots of call
center audio accumulating,
and you want to get
business insights out of it.
And then music
recommendation is just
an entire world unto itself.
And these are just a
sample of the types
of data that's accumulating
across all of your businesses
that could be very
valuable for you to process
with this cutting-edge
machine learning
and these cutting-edge
supercomputers.
So the good news is there's
been tremendous progress working
with unstructured
data, especially
over the past few years.
As you can see here, looking
at image recognition,
in this case on the
ImageNet standard benchmark,
there have been dramatic
increases in the top-1 accuracy
in just five years.
And the accuracy continues
to increase, especially
with some of these
new techniques,
like Learning to
Learn or Auto Amount.
And it's not just
image recognition.
This is not just about ImageNet.
These new deep neural
networks, and a sort
of broader class of
computationally intensive
new machine learning algorithms,
provide a unified approach
across many different
application domains,
ranging from imagery to
speech to text to scenes.
And this is a huge change from
when I was in grad school,
doing my PhD in computer vision.
The techniques weren't
very similar between say,
computer vision and natural
language processing.
Whereas now, you can use a
single computational framework,
whether that's TensorFlow
or another framework
of your choice, to express
many different model
architectures that all are built
under the same building blocks.
And those are the kinds
of building blocks
that we can now accelerate
with this new custom hardware.
So how do we manage
these profound increases
in computer requirements for
the most valuable new machine
learning applications?
Well, as you can see here, going
back to the image recognition
challenge on ImageNet,
the vertical axis
here is accuracy
of these models,
sort of a selection
of interesting models
over the past few years.
And then the horizontal
axis is computational cost.
And as you can see, to
get to those highest
levels of accuracy, you tend to
need more and more computation,
processing each image, and also
to train these models, even
on this data set of a
fixed size with ImageNet.
And so, in some
applications, you
can get away with
a lower accuracy.
And that's fine.
But in other
applications, when you
think about autonomous driving
or medical imaging or others,
every additional percentage
point of accuracy
is literally saving lives.
And so there's real urgency
to get at this space that's
currently bounded
by the computation
we can afford to apply.
So OpenAI recently published a
blog post called AI and Compute
where they did an analysis
similar to this one.
But now it's on a log scale.
You can see the vertical axis
is computation cost on a log
scale.
And then here they've
plotted this over time,
and highlighted
several models that
are especially well-known that
have provided new capabilities
over the past few years,
starting with AlexNet, which
kicked off this most
recent wave of excitement
about machine learning.
And then you see even
better image classification
models, as I showed
on the previous slide,
require even more compute.
But, again, it's
not just restricted
to image recognition.
We have speech
recognition models
like DeepSpeech2 in here.
We have machine translation
models requiring even more
compute to deliver these
amazing breakthrough results
in neural machine translation.
We have real-time game-playing
that OpenAI is working on,
and there will be more
this August there.
And then, also, world champion
Go-playing programs, up here,
demanding tremendous
amounts of compute
for the self-play
to learn the game
and learn the strategies
all on its own.
So if you step back and look at
this picture, what you really
see is that to get at these
valuable new capabilities,
you need to throw
as much compute
as you can at the problem.
And that's what's been driving
all this progress over time.
So OpenAI called out a
couple of important insights
that I'd like to highlight here.
And I won't read all these out.
I recommend that you look at
the blog post in its entirety.
But I'd say that, first
of all, the simple rule
seems to hold across a
wide variety of domains
that more compute seems
to lead predictably
to a little better
performance, as they say here
in the blog post.
And it's complementary
to algorithmic advances.
So it's great to try new
algorithms and new ideas.
And as I'll say later, there
are still lots of progress
to be made that way.
But that's complementary
to also having
an enormous amount of
compute to drive accuracy
as far as you can go
with the best ideas
that you've uncovered.
And now, in the lower
right here, this
is the most interesting insight
that the number to track
is not the speed of
your single accelerator
or the capacity of your
biggest data center,
but it's something in between.
It's the amount of compute
that you can productively
apply to train a single model.
This is what the folks
at OpenAI believe
is most likely to correlate
to how powerful the very
best models in the field are.
And it's really this that's
driving us-- not just to build
new chips or new
single machine systems,
but these connected
supercomputers that we call TPU
pods, because those are
enabling us to apply the largest
possible amount of compute
to train a single model that
can also be subdivided, too,
to train many models at once.
So how does this overview
relate to your business?
Well, there are two
perspectives that I
think you might find valuable.
You can come at this from the
point of view of the people
that you have in
your organization,
or that you're hoping to
hire, or acquire and bring
in their companies.
You can also think about this
from the perspective of data.
And I'll go through
these in turn.
So, first of all, people.
If you look around
in your organization,
and you have people who call
themselves machine learning
engineers, or machine
learning researchers,
it's obvious that they need
an enormous amount of compute.
They're typically
just budget-limited.
No matter how much
compute you have,
with all these models
that are so compute-hungry
and these enormous
data sets, they'll
rapidly find a way
to use the compute
that they have available.
And they'll ask you for more.
You're probably already hearing
them ask for as much compute
as they can get.
Also data scientists, though.
We and other teams
across the industry
are working hard to make
it easier and easier
to apply these techniques.
So even if you're
not ready to write
a model in raw
TensorFlow, that's
OK, because there are
more and more open
source reference
models available that
deliver high performance,
and can easily be adapted,
and can fit into sort of a more
standard data science workflow,
too, even for folks who don't
have a PhD in machine learning.
That's not required.
Furthermore, over in
product development,
it's an open question how to
take all these new capabilities
that are just newly being
exposed with machine learning
and use them to unlock new kinds
of experiences and services.
I think we're just in
the early stages of that.
At Google I/O this
year, we showed a demo
of Google Duplex, which is
a new way of interacting
with businesses
through the assistant.
That's just one example
of what I believe
is going to be a whole
forest of new opportunities
for new products to
take these capabilities
and integrate them in a
natural way into our lives.
Once you have those products,
and they're out in production,
your computer needs to scale
with your number of users.
If you have something
that hosted server-side,
and you have a
billion users, you've
got to handle billions
of requests coming in
simultaneously, and that
requires a lot of compute.
And in between,
research to production,
and, you know, even
once a model is live,
it's really important to
do continuous integration
and testing.
Machine learning models look a
lot different from the software
that you're probably
used to testing.
Subtle changes in
your input data
or any layer of
your compute stack
all the way down
can lead to changes
in accuracy of your model.
And so, it's important.
And what we do at
Google is we're
retraining these models all
the time on every new version
of our software, and
testing for regressions,
and passing as
much of that as we
can along to you through our
open source reference models.
And I'll say more
about that later.
But you'll need to do
this, too, for the products
that you develop and launch.
And I listed enthusiastic
interns here,
because I think it's
important not just to make
the compute available to
the people with the most
seniority, or the most obvious
titles in your organization,
like the ones that
I've listed before.
This whole field
is moving so fast.
There are so many students
being trained both
formally and informally
that it's possible
that someone who's just joined
your company as an intern,
who's sufficiently
motivated, could deliver
an enormous breakthrough
if they have access
to this level of compute,
and can work with the data
that you have, and talk
to your product team.
So I think it's really
important to make
this new large-scale
compute widely available,
both inside your
organizations and outside.
And that's what we're trying
to help all of you do.
So, in the past, the key
determinant of progress
was typically waiting for
your code to compile, right?
There's that famous
XKCD cartoon about this.
Now, in this new world of
working with enormous data sets
and training these gigantic
accurate ML models,
and then serving them,
the key determinant
of progress of your
team is how long
it takes for them to wait for
the machine learning models
to train.
And for production
models, this can currently
take weeks or even months.
And so, imagine if your
code took months to compile.
It's really important to pull
that in to hours, minutes, even
seconds, to make your
teams more productive,
let them try multiple
things at once,
get results, and iterate
instead of just waiting
for days or weeks or longer.
So now looking at this
from the data perspective.
Now, the kinds of ideal datasets
that I described earlier
for cutting-edge ML typically
have hundreds of thousands
of data points,
millions of data points,
or even billions of
data points in them.
And in most, but not all, of
these cutting-edge domains,
it's important to have
high-quality labels,
or at least the
ability to create them.
So typically with user-generated
content, photos, videos,
you might have tags that your
users are already applying.
In other cases, when you're
collecting geospatial imagery,
you can build a team
to label it or do
some sort of augmented
approach to labeling it.
And there are many labeling
services coming online now.
But there are also all
these sensors going out,
whether it's in mobile phones,
or autonomous vehicles,
or new kinds of robots, or
factories, or elsewhere.
And those are all
streaming data in that
can be valuable for
cutting-edge machine learning.
Simulations, too,
can be a valuable way
to generate data, whether
game environments,
or robotics simulations, or
other types of simulators.
And I call out here explicitly
at the bottom agents and robots
interacting with an environment.
You're currently seeing this
mostly on the research side
now.
But I think it won't be long
before you start seeing this
in real production systems.
But these are just
starting points for you
to look around your
business at all the data
that you have or could
easily collect and look
for data that's related
to the prediction problems
that matter.
Right?
And once you find a
large dataset there,
that's a good starting
point for figuring out
how to take this technology
and have an immediate impact
on your business.
So suppose you have the
people, you have the data.
What do you do next?
Well, I recommend that you
access the fastest hardware
that you can, and
ideally in the cloud.
And you might say, well,
what's the advantage
of going to the cloud?
I could just buy
some accelerators
and plug them in here.
We already have a data center.
That's where our data is.
Why should I change?
Well, the advantages,
especially of Google Cloud,
over on-prem hosting of
your own accelerators
are that you get a
lot of flexibility.
When you're planning for
your own data center,
there are these enormous lead
times, the capital expenses.
It's very complicated
to set things up.
And these new accelerators
are power-dense.
They're networking-dense.
They change a lot of
things about the way
that you need to plan
your data center.
We announced at Google I/O that
our Version 3 TPUs are actually
liquid cooled.
So, you know, if you
think that that's
a signal of where
the field is going,
do you want to bring liquid
cooling into your data center?
It's complicated.
Whereas in the cloud, you can
just mix and match in software
the components that you need.
You can provision quickly and
scale up as your needs change,
or scale back down if a
burst of traffic has passed,
and now that you're
in a short lull.
There's built-in security.
I think one thing
that you've heard
throughout this conference
is that Google Cloud is
the leader in security.
And we have powerful
tools for data access user
control and more.
I encourage you to consult
the other sessions just
to see how deep
Google's commitment is
to security in the cloud.
And as I mentioned
at the beginning,
reducing capital expenses
is really fantastic.
On-demand pricing and
preemptible pricing
lets you pay only for what you
need, and scale up and down.
So now let's talk
about these TPUs.
And these TPUs are
only in Google Cloud.
Our Version 1 is actually
not in the cloud.
This is in our data
center since 2015.
It was our first foray into the
space, when Jeff Dean worried
that if every Android user
talked to their phones
for just three minutes a
day, the speech recognition
algorithm that we were
running at the time
would have required us to double
our number of data centers.
So that wasn't going to work.
And so there was
this crash project
to develop an
accelerator that you now
interact with every
time you run a search,
or you use Google
Photos, or street view,
or a bunch of Google's
other services,
are running either on
this or its successors.
Now here is the Cloud TPU.
This is an example of Google's
second generation TPUs
in a system that's
widely available today.
No signup required.
No waiting.
This is now generally available.
It's in the United States.
It's in Europe.
It's in Asia.
And you can find out more
by going to g.co/cloudtpu.
The nice thing about these
TPUs is that they weren't just
single machine systems, though.
Like I mentioned
before, they're designed
to be connected together into
these enormous supercomputers
that we call TPU pods.
And the exciting
thing here, that's
been mentioned obliquely, but
I want to make very clear,
is that our Cloud TPU
pod with these v2 TPUs
is now available in alpha.
And you'll hear a little
bit more later about
how people have
already been using it
to accelerate their businesses.
Furthermore, as you may
have heard in the keynotes,
v3 is also in alpha.
And so, if you're
interested in trying out
the next generation
of performance,
contact Cloud Sales
or Cloud Support
and get access to
these amazing machines.
Also, we revealed that these
v3 TPUs, just like the v2,
are designed to be
connected together
to even larger
liquid-cooled supercomputers
that we revealed at Google I/O.
So what I'm trying
to show you here
is that we're deeply committed
to making relentless progress
in performance, in cost,
in scale, of these kinds
of accelerators for both
inference and training,
and to pass those benefits
along to you, and in businesses,
in universities, as
individuals, in startups,
all around the world.
So as you can see
here, we've gone
from 92 teraops
and inference only,
to 180 teraflops for
training and inference
with the Cloud TPU v2.
And then with v3, we're now
going with a single device,
that you see pictured
here, up to 420 teraflops.
We've also doubled the memory.
And this is really important
if batch sizes have
been a limitation
for you, or you
want to go to a
larger models that
are difficult to fit on a single
device that you have today.
Now suddenly your
device has 420 teraflops
and 128 gigabytes of RAM.
Extremely high
bandwidth RAM, actually.
So that's in alpha.
Check it out.
Looking at the pods, the
pod that's available today
is 11 and 1/2 petaflops,
4 terabytes of RAM,
and this mesh network
that makes for really
efficient communication without
any code changes on your part.
And then the TPU v3
pod that we announced
that I/O goes above
100 petaflops with 32
terabytes of RAM.
So this is not just thinking
a lot more of the same machine
together, it's a whole
new chip architecture
in addition to this
larger scale system that
really delivered these results.
Furthermore, I want to call
out that, as of yesterday,
here at Cloud Next, Cloud GPU
pricing has gotten even better.
We've got promotional pricing
that we've introduced across
all of our regions that takes
the price for renting a Cloud
TPU in your central, for
example, down to $4.50 an hour.
And the amazing thing is, if
you can tolerate checkpointing
and occasionally having to
recover your work if it gets
interrupted, which
is an easy thing
to do in machine learning,
you can use preemptible TPUs
for just $1.35 an hour.
This is an unprecedented
step to make machine learning
more affordable for everyone.
And so we hope that this
helps you both get started
with our new platform
comfortably, and for those
of you in these
larger organizations,
to scale up way
beyond anything you
are able to contemplate now.
So what's the user experience
for these Cloud TPUs?
Well, today, the best way
to program these Cloud TPUs
is with TensorFlow.
And, in particular, TensorFlow
is a wide and vast open source
framework for machine learning.
Its the most popular
in the world.
On GitHub, it's one of
the top five projects
on GitHub overall.
And programming TPUs to get
the highest performance,
you'll typically use a subset
of the TensorFlow APIs,
tf.data to manage your input
processing, layers, estimators,
and then you go through
the XLA compiler,
over there in the lower right.
To give you a sense of
what this looks like--
and by the way, these APIs
are not specific to TPUs.
If you implement
your models this way,
our intention over
time is for it
to require less and
less change for you
to just flip a
configuration flag
and run your code
on GPU or on CPU.
So we're really trying
to get to the point where
you can write your machine
learning models once, and then
transparently take advantage
of whatever hardware
you have available, and
deploy on whatever hardware
you want out at the edge,
whether that's in a phone,
or in a vehicle, or in some
other edge application.
So focusing on layers and
estimators for a second,
though, here's some sample code
of a typical computer vision
model, unmodified for TPU.
And then here's an example
of the types of modifications
you have to make today.
And, again, we're trying
to reduce these over time.
Just a couple of lines
have changed here
around the optimizer
and the estimator.
And so, I want to
emphasize, though,
that you're not just limited
to TensorFlow programming TPUs.
A lot of people
think, oh, well, what
if I use some other framework
or what if I want flexibility
to try multiple
ways of interacting
with these accelerators?
That's just fine.
And in fact, as of
TensorFlow 1.10,
we announced here at Cloud
Next that we have initial Keras
integration with Cloud TPUs.
And this gives you even more
flexibility and convenience.
And it gives you
an incremental path
for taking the Keras
code that you have today,
running it on the TPU, and
then gradually optimizing
the performance maybe
of the input pipeline
or of other parts of
it to get, to unlock
more and more of the
performance that these Cloud
TPUs can deliver.
So if you're choosing
between one or the other,
the way to think about
this is, on the left,
TPUEstimator gives
you peak performance.
Right?
It scales to pods with
zero code changes,
which is truly amazing,
if you've ever tried
to write a distributed system.
This is a fantastic convenience.
It's got some error robustness.
You can easily export
models for inference
on CPUs, GPUs, or TPUs.
And then Keras has sort of
a complementary advantage
with easy development,
non-static shapes, NumPy input,
and then experimental
tf.data integration.
So definitely recommend
trying them both
and seeing which one
better suits your use case.
Cloud TPUs are
integrated tightly
with TensorBoard, which lets you
track what your model is doing.
And we have this
fantastic profiler tab
that lets you
capture TPU profiles
and examine them
in enormous detail.
People have given us tremendous
feedback, positive feedback,
on how valuable this is to
understand what their models
are doing on this new hardware.
This is something
that people really
love that are using TPUs today.
For example, we even
have a frame here
that calls out in red--
I don't know if
you can read it--
but it's telling you that your
program is not input bounded.
So this is a great
time to optimize
the mapping of your
model onto the hardware.
Whereas in other cases, it
might say, you're input bounded.
Don't worry about the model.
Optimize your input
pipeline, because you're not
able to feed data
fast enough to keep up
with these accelerators.
I'd also like to emphasize
that Cloud TPUs are
different in another way that
gives you more flexibility.
They're network-attached
rather than
being directly attached
to your virtual machine.
And what that means is, you,
the customer, here on the left,
this particular customer
is here in the room,
is connected to an
arbitrary Compute Engine VM,
in the center there.
That can be whatever
you want-- large, small.
And it can actually
be very small,
because all the heavy
compute is happening
behind the scenes
on the Cloud TPUs,
so that can be an
N1 standard, too.
You don't need a
big VM to drive.
And then communicating over
network with this Cloud TPU,
ordinary open
source TensorFlow is
able to drive your computation.
You know, reading in data
from GCS or elsewhere.
Now we've got Cloud
Bigtable integrations,
and gRPC integrations, and
other ways of getting data
into these devices.
But also that Cloud
TPU doesn't have
to just be a single device.
It be a whole slice of a pod.
And so this extra
network step means
you don't have to fight
with drivers anymore.
You just use these machine
images that we provide.
And you can scale
up and down easily
from an infrastructure
point of view,
as well as from a
code point of view.
So let me say a little bit more
about scaling up on these pods.
So from a samples-per-second
point of view,
these pods are
designed to scale.
And so you see perfect
linear scaling behavior
in terms of, in this case,
with Resonant 50, a while
back, how many images
were processed per second
as we scaled up the
number of devices
connected with our special
super fast network.
I just want to
emphasize, again, this
means distributed training
of machine learning models
can finally be easy.
There are fantastic
contributions outside.
There's TensorFlow.
There's Horovod.
There's other
things, which, if you
have a bespoke cluster within
infiniband that can really
scale, and all the
expertise to operate it,
you can achieve
fantastic results.
But this is, I think,
the easiest way
to achieve this level of scale
in any public cloud today.
Furthermore, you
might wonder, well,
but if I make the
batch sizes that large,
is my model still
going to converge?
And the answer is, it depends.
But the research is
looking very promising.
There is very active
research on this right now.
And what you're seeing
here is on the time axis,
that orange dot is a
single device training
a model to a certain accuracy.
And then you can see here, as
we've tuned the hyperparameters
and gone to a larger and
larger slice of the pod,
you can still hit
that same accuracy,
but in much less time.
So I'm thrilled that eBay,
who's been using these Cloud TPU
pods, has been able to take
advantage of this benefit
already for their
visual search models
to achieve enormous
speedups on much larger data
sets than ImageNet.
And one of our
colleagues from eBay's
here in the audience today.
So the challenge
is visual search,
which is an enormous part
of the eBay experience.
Customers all over the world are
listing more than one billion
products, and need to be
able to find what they want,
when they want it.
But even with the training image
set that's a subset of that,
55 million images, training a
model with on-premise hardware
was taking months.
And it was impossible
to iterate and try out
new things as quickly as the
computer vision team wanted to.
So, to scale further, eBay
switched to the Cloud TPU pods
that are now available
to everybody in alpha,
with the goal of delivering
a new image classification
model optimized for
TPUs, and then finding
the right hyperparameter
settings for their extremely
large dataset.
I'm happy to report that the
results have been fantastic.
And the progress is continuing.
So, in some cases,
it's hard to do
an apples-to-apples comparison
between something that
was trained for
months and months
with something that's
trained in just a few days.
But in some cases,
the speedup was
almost 100x over
the hardware system
that they'd been
using previously.
And, when you pick
the best model
of the ones that were
tested, the accuracy boost
was 10%, which is enormous
for a production model.
So what this means
is that eBay is now
closer to continuous
machine learning, training
multiple models each week
to keep product search
results fresh, pulling
in new advances
from cutting-edge research
that's being published
in the open all the time.
We think this is a
really promising step
towards reinventing the way
that eBay's customers visually
shop and experience the site.
So let me say a little bit
more about performance,
since I know that
that's something that's
interesting to all of
you who are pushing up
against the limits of whatever
setup you currently have.
Now, it's important to
measure performance carefully.
Often you'll see
isolated statistics out
of context thrown
around on the internet.
This many samples per second,
or this many times faster,
or what have you.
It's really ideal-- it's
not always possible,
but it's really ideal to
focus on real-world data,
on time-to-accuracy, and cost in
an apples-to-apples comparison
across two different systems.
And so when I say real-world
data, what I mean here
is that often you'll
see results that
are achieved with synthetic
data, which just means
random numbers fed
through to the device
to see how fast it can run.
It's like lifting a
car off the pavement,
and then flooring
the accelerator,
and measuring how
fast the wheels spin.
It's cool.
It makes a loud noise.
But what you really care about
is the whole system performance
of a real dataset
flowing into your system
without any bottlenecks,
and being processed
to get to the results that
you want, or serve the models
that matter to your customers
Also, you'll often hear
people report results
without saying anything
about convergence
to the expected accuracy.
But, ultimately, that's
what matters to you
and your business.
If you're doing a pedestrian
detector for autonomous
driving, it really is
important how accurate
that pedestrian
detector model is.
And even a loss of
a percentage point
is something that you take very
seriously, and want to avoid.
So, finally, we're
trying to move away
from chip-to-chip or
system-to-system comparisons,
because they're going to
be increasingly meaningless
as there's this Cambrian
explosion of new hardware
architectures to deal with
the end of Moore's Law.
And instead, we're
trying to look
at the total cost of one
system versus another
in the public clouds that
are accessible to everybody.
Finally, we're investing
a lot of energy
in making ML benchmarks
reproducible via open source
implementations.
So you don't have to
trust my word for it.
You can take
anything that you're
about to see, run it
yourselves on Cloud TPUs,
and see if you measure
the same results.
The best and most
carefully designed
contest we've seen so far has
been organized by some Stanford
researchers.
It's called DAWNBench.
And they really focused
on these metrics
that I just mentioned,
time-to-accuracy
and total cost, especially
on ImageNet, but also
on CIFAR-10 and
question-answering dataset.
And so I'm happy to report
that Cloud TPUs came
in number one in DAWNBench
for ImageNet training cost,
hitting their accuracy in
just 7.5 hours for under $50.
But now, the field
is moving so fast,
this was earlier
this year, already
with the new
promotional pricing,
that comes down to $34.
And with preemptibles,
that's just over $10,
which is kind of amazing.
But wait, there's more.
If we look at the ResNet
results here, which at that time
were achieving something
like 3,250 images a second,
and hitting the
accuracy that you
expect in just under nine
hours, that cost just under $60.
Now that's down to $40,
running the exact same code,
or just under $13 at
preemptible prices.
The pod, as I promised,
scales up linearly.
So a half-pod was able
to get the job done, not
in hours, but in 30 minutes.
And, actually, that
includes a lot of overhead
that doesn't really make a
lot of sense at this scale,
because you end up having to
checkpoint every few seconds
as you're getting through the
DAWNBench challenge, which
you wouldn't do in real life.
So if you eliminate the
checkpoint overhead,
that's just 23.9 minutes to
get to this level of accuracy.
That's really what I
mean about enabling teams
to iterate faster than
they ever could before.
SPEAKER 2: How
much did that cost?
SPEAKER 1: Good question.
Talk to Sales.
So pricing is not
announced for alpha,
but I highly encourage you
to talk to our sales team
to get a sense of
what this will cost.
Furthermore, I'd like to
say that at DAWNBench there
was a third-place entry
that was very clever.
It was from a team
called fast.ai.
And they had an entry
at $72 at the time
that had two clever tricks.
One was progressively
scaling up the image size
during training,
because you don't
need the higher resolution
at the very beginning,
it turns out.
And they also used a more
aggressive learning rate
schedule.
And so after the
contest, we reproduced
these algorithmic
changes on the Cloud TPU,
and open sourced the
changes, and that
takes ResNet-50 training
costs on Cloud TPU
from the new $40.83 down to $17.
And that is affordable even with
predictable on-demand pricing.
But with preemptible
pricing, the cost
is now down to just $5.
So we're obviously trying to
drive this as close to zero
as we can, because
we know that you
need to train these
models over and over again
to make progress.
And you want to
train a lot of them
in parallel to do a gigantic
hyperparameter search
or neural architecture
search on every new product
that you're going to release.
So to experience
this performance,
like I mentioned
before, Cloud TPUs
are now GA and widely available.
Start with our Quickstart
or our tutorials.
Use one of our reference models.
And, hopefully, this
will be helpful to you.
So where do we go
from DAWNBench?
Well, there a new benchmark
conference in town
that's even more
comprehensive and challenging
that's organized across
many different institutions,
companies, universities.
And you can find more
information at MLPerf,
mlperf.org.
I think this is going to be
really exciting with results
for our version 0.5 of the
benchmark late this October.
So how do you start using these
Cloud TPUs, or TPU pods, today?
Well, I recommend that you
start with one of our reference
models.
And I want to
emphasize that we have
a wide range of these
reference models
that are great starting points.
Even if you're heavily invested
in some model in-house,
it's useful to step back
and say, well, wait.
What is the
underlying task here?
Whether it's object detection or
speech recognition or language
processing or
something else, and see
if we have a reference model
that corresponds to that task.
Because then, just
as a baseline,
you can take your data, connect
it to our reference model--
and here's a whole range
of our reference models--
and immediately get a
result in just a few days,
maybe even an
afternoon, before you
think about the more intensive
process of taking your existing
model, and porting it over to a
new system, and optimizing it.
So as you can see here, we've
got image recognition, object
detection, machine translation,
language modeling, speech
recognition, and even
image generation,
some of the cutting-edge
stuff, over on the right,
and we're adding new
models all the time.
So I'll highlight
a few of these,
and provide some new
performance numbers,
and sort of a mini-case
study on object detection.
So you've heard a lot
about image classification.
I'd like to just call out that
our AmoebaNet-D model that
won DAWNBench is actually
an architecture that
was discovered through neural
architecture search on the TPU.
So it's a model that was
designed from scratch
on the TPU, made available
open source for all of you,
and it achieves fantastic
accuracy on ImageNet, and also
on larger data sets.
Object detection is
really interesting,
because here you're
processing larger images
and trying to localize many
different objects within them.
And so, back in Google I/O
in May, I showed this result,
but I've updated
the prices here for
our new promotional pricing.
You're processing
896 by 896 images.
And at that time, we
achieve 37 average precision
on COCO, which is pretty
good, in just six hours.
And now that would cost
you only $28, or just $9
with preemptibles.
But with TensorFlow 1.9, we've
made even greater advances
in efficiency.
And that means if
you're willing to let
this run just a little bit
longer, you can get to 37.7 AP
on COCO.
So that's up from 37.
That's pretty cool.
It's not that much
more expensive.
But now, this is just
without any code changes
going from TPU v2 to TPU
v3, because, remember,
this is a family of processors.
We want to make it
as easy as possible
for you to scale up
from, whether it's
one device up to a pod, or from
one generation to the next.
So here, RetineNet
with TensorFlow 1.9
can achieve that same
37.7 average position
on COCO in just 4.1 hours.
So it's 1.5x faster
with no code changes.
And we've barely begun to
optimize for the new platform.
What's even more
interesting than that
is what happens when you
have this additional memory
available.
Right?
Because the memory
doubles for v2 to v3.
So, suddenly, without a
lot of engineering effort,
you can process 1024
by 1024 images, which
I know is something
that's really
interesting to a lot
of autonomous driving
companies or medical imaging
companies that want to process
the largest images they can.
Suddenly, you're up to
38.4 average precision.
Remember, up from 37
originally, in just 5.2 hours.
And now that you're able
to iterate at this larger
scale and larger speed, you
try out some data augmentation
techniques, and that gets
you to 41 average precision
in just 10 hours, letting
it run a little longer.
So this is a great
concrete example
of the general principle
I introduced before--
the faster hardware, and also
larger memory in this case,
gives you the opportunity for
more experimentation and even
higher accuracy
for the models that
matter most to your business.
Furthermore, I'm thrilled
to announce that image
segmentation is coming soon.
So we've got the
DeepLab v3 model coming.
Mask R-CNN, which I
know is a popular model
out there, and more, for
those of you who don't just
want bounding
boxes, but you want
to know pixel by pixel where
each object is in an image.
I'll just emphasize
that TPUs are not
only about computer vision.
Here's machine translation with
transformer achieving a near
state-of-the-art blue score on
WMT 14 from English to German,
6.2 hours, under $30, under
$10 for the preemptible.
It's fantastic.
Language modeling, it's more
compute-intensive to train
on the language model
one-billion-word dataset.
But this is the
kind of thing that
lets you do things like Smart
Reply or Smart Compose, that's
helpful for messaging
apps and any kind
of conversational interaction
where you want to save people
time predicting what's next.
And this is an example
of one of several models
that's in Tensor2Tensor.
There's a link down
here at the bottom.
Two is a numeral, and
it's all one word.
And Tensor2Tensor is built
on top of TensorFlow.
It's great for research,
mixing and matching
data sets, small architectures,
training processes.
And you'll see a few others
like this one also there.
So speech recognition
here, we've
got ASR Transformer giving you
a great word error rate in just
13 hours, 7.9 word error rate.
And you can get down
to 7.3, if you're
willing to let it
train a little longer.
And, again, preemptible
pricing, just under 20 bucks.
Finally-- well, almost
finally-- question answering.
This was the winner of the
DAWNBench Question Answering
Contest.
And the team has continued
to make improvements such
that this now trains
in just eight minutes.
I've written estimated
training costs here,
because this is
now so fast we may
have to rethink the other
overheads to see how to measure
this cost accurately.
It's too small to even register.
And that question
answering model
now has an open source
implementation available,
which is great.
So also at the cutting edge
of research image generation,
bits per dimension is
the key metric here.
And lower is actually better.
So this 2.98 is close to the
2.92 that's state of the art.
For just $130, or $44
with preemptible pricing,
you can generate these images
from scratch that look weirdly
like real life, but not quite.
So I think this is a really
interesting research domain.
So please consider starting
with a reference model.
Even if you love the model
that you've already built,
even if you've sunk an enormous
amount of engineering effort
into it, it's really valuable to
just lay down a quick baseline
with a public dataset, or with
one of your in-house datasets,
using these reference models
to then guide your engineering
choices, whether it's
porting your existing model,
maybe merging it with some
of our reference code,
or starting with a
reference model fresh,
and then building from there.
So these reference models
are high performance.
They're open source.
They're cutting-edge.
You know, some of the latest
and greatest research,
like AmoebaNet, is
immediately pushed
into this pool of reference
models that are open source.
We're doing a lot of continuous
testing for performance
and accuracy to save you as
much of that trouble as we can,
because we know it's
complicated and expensive.
And these reference models let
you get up and running quickly,
training on your own data.
But I want to
emphasize you're not
limited to reference models.
For example, here's another case
study of architecture research
that a group at Stanford
did where they actually
did parallel runs using hundreds
of Cloud TPUs simultaneously.
Each blue dot in this image is
a run training an ImageNet scale
Convolutional RNN on a TPU.
So this is a lot of
computation here.
They were searching
for a model--
there's an archive
link in lower right--
"Task-Driven Convolutional
Recurrent Models of the Visual
System" is the paper--
and they were looking
for a model that
was a better fit for
the types of dynamics
that you record if you put
electrodes in the brain
and actually listen to
the primate visual cortex
as it's seeing.
And so, here's a diagram
of the sort of space
that they were searching.
And it turns out that
across this population
of many different
models, they found
that these red connections were
selected for during the search
versus the others.
And then when they
went back and tried
to fit these models
to some of the signals
that they were actually
recording in primates,
they found that these
Convolutional RNNs
were a much better fit for
the neural signals in v4,
in IT, than typical just
ordinary convolutional
feed-forward models
that you see typically
in the literature today.
So I think this is an
interesting new research
direction.
And it's a group that was
able to do this from scratch
on their own, using
hundreds of Cloud TPUs.
So you can not only
implement your own models,
you can search for models
automatically using Cloud TPUs.
So I want to just share a
little bit more information
about the hardware,
just give you
a flavor of what makes
these accelerators
different from other
types of processors that
are available on the market.
So the Cloud TPU
that I mentioned
before consists of this device
here, which under those heat
sinks has four separate
processors and all of this 64
gigabytes of high bandwidth
memory with a very high memory
bandwidth among the processors.
And it's connected
to a host server,
like you see here, with PCI v3.
And so let's zoom in on just one
of these chips in the Cloud TPU
device.
Well, that chip has
a layout like this.
It's got two cores.
And it's got a scaler unit.
It's got a vector unit.
And most importantly,
it's got this matrix unit,
which is this gigantic
systolic array.
That's an old idea in
hardware architecture,
but it's newly relevant
now that so many
of these cutting-edge models
use dense linear algebra.
It's really the perfect fit
for this systolic array.
One interesting thing
about this systolic array
is that while it's doing
float32 accumulate, like you're
used to, it's actually using
a different filling point
format behind the scenes with no
code changes for you necessary,
although you can take
further advantage of bfloat16
if you want.
So it's using bfloat16
and it multiplies.
And let me tell you a little
bit more about what that means,
because I think this is one
of the unique advantages
of the Cloud TPU.
So float32 IEEE floating
point has this enormous range.
And those 32 bits are
divided as you see here
with the exponent and
then the mantissa.
Lots of bits for the mantissa
to track these fine differences
between numbers.
That's important for high
performance computing
where you're tracking fine
details in a simulation,
but it turns out it doesn't
matter that much in machine
learning.
So some vendors have
gone to IEEE float16,
which you can see here,
which reduces both
the exponent and the mantissa.
And what that means is you
end up reducing the range.
And now if you're
programming with float16,
you have to completely rewrite
your model in a different way
on a model-by-model basis.
It's very time-consuming
and subtle,
because you have to keep
all of your activations
in the right ranges.
You might have to
do loss rescaling.
We're trying in TensorFlow
to make this more convenient,
but it's really hard.
And so we actually use a
different floating point format
in the TPU that we
call the bfloat16,
for the brain team, which
is where we started this.
And there we preserve
the apex of exponents,
and just chop off the mantissa.
Turns out, this is also
a drop in replacement
for float32 across this huge
range of machine learning
models that we see.
You only have to be careful in
a few small situations-- maybe
atom has a parameter
that you've got
to be careful to
explicitly cast a float32,
because there are so many
nines after the decimal point.
But in general, it's much
easier to work with bfloat16
than with float32.
And then that reduces
your memory usage
and avoids memory bottlenecks.
It's fantastic.
And if you want to
see how bloat16 works,
a lot of our reference
models are already
using it transparently.
So you can see some
examples in, you know,
the GitHub TensorFlow
TPU repository.
So just to illustrate briefly
how this matrix unit actually
does magic, here's
a 3 by 3 example,
but imagine this is 128 by
128, which is what we really
have on the device.
So what's happening as
the data's streaming in
is we're getting a
lot of great reuse
of these intermediate results
within the systolic array
in this staggered fashion that's
producing the output that we
want.
And so as long as your problem
has some dense linear algebra
core that can be
mapped efficiently
to these systolic
arrays, which we found
is possible across this
wide range of applications
that I called out
earlier, this is
going to be a great fit for your
machine learning, both training
and also inference.
So stepping back
for just a second.
We've covered a lot.
I just want to
emphasize Cloud TPU v2.
It's now GA, it's
widely available.
It's in the US.
It's in Asia.
It's in Europe.
We've got regular pricing.
We've got preemptible pricing.
It's an incredibly affordable
way to start with one
of our state-of-the-art
reference models and explore
this frontier if
you haven't yet.
Or if you're one
of these folks part
of or leading a team of these
cutting-edge machine learning
engineers and
researchers, they'll
thank you for having access
to orders of magnitude
more compute than you could
possibly have afforded before.
We've also gone through how to
measure performance carefully
and looked at some
of these applications
across all these different
domains-- not just
image recognition, but also
speech, language, image
generation.
And one other thing I'd
like to highlight here
is that Cloud TPUs--
I focused on using Cloud TPUs
in Google Compute Engine,
but that's just the lowest
level of the stack, where
we're giving you maximum
flexibility and control.
We're also working to
integrate Cloud TPUs with all
of the rest of Google Cloud.
On the storage side, which
I haven't written here,
with GCS, but also with
Bigtable, and with Arbitrade,
gRPC services, and then
here with Cloud ML engine,
if you want to use a
higher-level managed
service to keep track
of all your training
jobs, and Kubernetes
GKE, there's
a really interesting
talk tomorrow on Minigo,
training an AlphaGo
Zero-like model on hundreds
of Cloud TPUs using GKE.
It's going to be
a fantastic talk,
so check it out, and look
for the recording afterwards.
So we're really
introducing a new platform
for machine learning.
It works well with TensorFlow,
but also with Keras.
And we're looking at
other frameworks as well.
And we hope it'll
be valuable to you,
as you're developing
cutting-edge new
machine-learning-enabled
applications for your customers
all around the world.
So thanks very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]